[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
هذه صور بدايه من العاصمه نيام عاصمه
النيجر قبل انتهاء مهله الايكواس لقاده
الانقلاب لاعاده السلطه للرئيس بازومي
وهذه هي صور جاءت قبل قليل من مدينه جنين
حيث قالت مصادر ان اجهزه السلطه
الفلسطينيه قمعت مظاهره مؤيده لعمليه وقعت
مساء اليوم في تل ابيب
وهذه الصور من العاصمه البرتغاليه لشبونه
التي يزورها بابا الفاتيكان الفرنسيس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قبيل انتهاء مهله الاكواس رئيس وزراء
النيجر يقول للجزيره ان الامل قائم
بالوصول الى حل تفاوضي ويؤكد ثقه حكومته
بتقدير الاكواس العسكري بشان التدخل
المحتمل وباريس تعلن دعما موقف المنظمه
وقاده الانقلاب يصرون على عدم التراجع عن
تعليق الدستور والاطاحه بالرئيس وتقارير
تتحدث عن طلبهم مساعده ميليشيا فاغنر في
مالي
في اليوم الثاني مواجهه محتدمه في البحر
الاسود مسيره بحريه تستهدف ناقله نفط
روسيه تقول انها كانت مخصصه لتزويد الجيش
بالوقود وتقول ان سته موانئ روسيه في
دائره الاستهداف
وبعد توعد موسكو بالرد استهداف كييف
بصواريخ كروز
يقول ان ضربه روسيه اصابت شركه تصنيع
طائرات
وسائل اعلام الاسرائيليه تؤكد مقتل شرطي
متاثرا باصابته في عمليه تل ابيب الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تقول انها قتلت المنفر وتؤكد
انه جاء من جنين
تينياهو يعقد اجتماعا امنيا غدا والفصائل
تعتبر العمليه ردا على ما سمتها جرائم
الاحتلال
مع استمرار المعارك في مدن العاصمه
السودانيه الثلاث الجيش يعلن تكبيد الدعم
السريع خسائر كبيره والدعم يقول انه ما
زال يحاصر مقر القياده العامه ونائبه رئيس
البعثه الامميه تحذر من وصول الوضع
الانساني الى مرحله مريعه وتطلب دعما
دوليا عاجلا
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم
التعديلات القضائيه التي يواجهها رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
حيث قالت صحيفه يدع الاحرنوت ان 100 من
كبار المسؤولين السابقين في منظومه الدفاع
الاسرائيليه عقدوا مؤتمرا طارئا لمناقشه
التعامل مع سيناريوهات انهيار النظام
واساليب العمل لحمايه المحكمه العليا
والجيش والشرطه في حاله انهيار النظام في
اسرائيل حسب ما قالت الصحيفه لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي هل تعتقدون ان ازمه
التغييرات القضائيه تهدد بانهيار النظام
في اسرائيل جاءت النتيجه على النحو التالي
نحو 36% صوت بنعم بينما قال اربعون في
المئه ان ازمه التغييرات لا تهدد بانهيار
النظام في اسرائيل واخيرا قام 24% ان متى
ستؤثر على مستقبل وجود النظام هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلال لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
قبيله انتهاء مهنه الاكواس قال مصدر عسكري
في نيامي للجزيره ان الجيش لا يتراجع عن
خطواته بتعليق الدستور والاطاحه بالرئيس
محمد بازون وكان مفوض مجموعه ايكواس عبد
الفتاح موسى قال ان قاده اركان جيوش
المجموعه وضعوا خطه لتدخل عسكري محتمل في
النيجر تشمل كيفيه وتوقيت نشر القوات واكد
المفوض ان ايكواس لن تبلغ قاده الانقلاب
في النيجر بمكان وموعد ضربتها مؤكدا رغبه
المجموعه في ان تنجح الدبلوماسيه وانها
تمنح قاده الانقلاب كل الفرص لتراجع
من جانبها قالت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ان التهديد باللجوء الى التدخل العسكري في
النيجر يجب ان يؤخذ على محمل الجد واضافت
ان امام الانقلابيين مهله حتى يوم غد لوقف
ما وصفتها بالمغامره واعاده الديمقراطيه
كما جددت كولونا دعم فرنسا الكامل للرئيس
محمد بازوم وحكومته واكدت وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه دعمها جهود ايكواس لاحباط محاوله
الانقلاب في النيجر
هذا ونقلت وكاله استشهدت بريس عن مسؤول
عسكري غربي ان قاده الانقلاب في النيجر
طلب المساعده من مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
الموجوده في مالي للتعامل مع التدخل
العسكري المحتمل لمجموعه اكواس وذكرت
الوكاله ان احد قاده الانقلاب زار مالي
واجرى اتصالات مع احد افراد فاغنر وابلغه
بحاجه قاده الانقلاب لمساعده المجموعه
عن هذه التصريحات كنت قد سالت رئيس وزراء
النيجر حمودو محمد محمد وفي مقابله قبل
الحصاد وعن رسالتهم كحكومه مع قرب انتهاء
مهله الاكواس
في النيجر نحن حاليا نعيش ماساه لان
الرئيس الحرس الرئاسي
اقامه باحتجاز الرئيس
وحول احتجاز هذا الى محاوله انقلاب وهذا
ما ادى الى ان الاكواس وبموجب بروتوكول
الحكم الرشيد والديمقراطيه الذي جرت
تصديقه من قبل كل دول الاعضاء مجبر على
التدخل وتطبيق بنود هذا البروتوكول وبيوجب
هذا البروتوكول واحكامه فان منظمه الاكواس
اعطت مهله للشخص الذي يحتجز رئيسه جمهوريه
لتحريره
[موسيقى]
واعادته الى منصبه كرئيس وايضا
عاده كل المؤسسات الديمقراطيه التي وافق
عليها الشعب بحريه اذا هذه ماساه
لاننا في على بعد ساعات من المهله التي
منحت ولحد الان لم نحصل على ردين ايجابي
على الطلب قدمته
ومع ذلك ما زال لدينا الامل لانه طالما ان
المهله المعطاه من قبل منظمه لما تنتهي
فان ما زال لدينا امل بانه يمكن التواصل
الى حل تفاوضي لهذه المشكله هل انتم مع
التدخل العسكريا في حال عدم التجاوب مع
هذه المطالب
نحن
لسنا من طالبنا بهذا التدخل العسكري ولا
ولا طالبنا بفرض عقوبات التي فرضتها
مجموعه الاكواس فهذه عقوبات فرضت على
النيجر بموجب
البروتوكول الذي صادغت عليه جمهوريه
النيجر السيد محمد هناك من يرى ان التدخل
عسكري في النيجر يحمل مخاطر كبيره على كل
غرب افريقيا وليس فقط في النيجر في ظل
مواقف كمالي وبوركينا فاسو حتى كثير من
دول الجوار ترفض التدخل عسكريا في النيجر
اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر هل هو محسوب
العواقب
انا قلت قبل قليل عندها في مقدمه باننا
نعيش ماساه وفعلا
لو انه لم يحصل تدخل
عسكري فان ذلك سيكون ماساه للمنطقه اذا
تركزت نجح هذا الانقلاب كما تعلمون حصلت
ثلاثه انقلابات في غرب افريقيا وهذا سيكون
الرابع واذا ما نجح هذا الانقلاب الرابع
فهذا فتاكدوا انه انتقلابات اخرى مستقبلا
وبالتالي ان النيجر بلد
يعمل يعمل كسد الحمايه ضد تمدد وتوسع
المجموعات الارهابيه نحو الجنوب واذا ما
هذا الانقلاب نجح وتركز فان هذا البلد
يفقد استقراره
والمجموعات الارهابيه ستجد وسائل
واسهلدهم للتوغل قدما نحو الجنوب وبالنسبه
بالنسبه لهذه المنطقه هذا مصدر قلق شديد
وانتم تقولون لو انه حصل انتخاب التدخل
عسكري فان ذلك يمكن ان يكون مشكله بالنسبه
للمنطقه نعم يمكن ان يكون مشكله ذلك لكل
المنطقه ولكن الامر كله سيعتمد على طبيعه
التدخل هذا وبهذا الصدد نحن نستطيع ان نثق
بالخبراء العسكريين ضمن مجموعه
الذي يكون حاليا بوضع مفهوم خطه هذا
التدخل الذي توقعنا حصوله في حاله نفترض
الى القيام به على هذه الثقه اجتماع لقاده
الاركان على مستوى الايكواس وتم رفع
التوصيات لقاده الدول في مجموعه الاكواس
هل انتم مطلعون على هذه الخطه هنا اعني
خطه التدخل العسكري طبعا في حال عدم
التجاوب مع مطالب الاكواس
لا استطيع ان اعرف ما الذي توصل اليه
منخطه لان هذا كان اجتماع
الاركان وكان اجتماعا مغلقا ما اعرفه انهم
اعلنوا بانهم قد وضعوا مفهومه للعمليه
العسكريه
وقد حددوا الوسائل
وما يحتاجونه من تسهيلات
وبالتالي ان يبقى الامر على الرسائل الدول
اذا اذا ما تقرر وقرروا ان هذا التدخل
العسكري لا مفر منه ضروري لكن كما قلت قبل
قليل مازال لدينا يوم ونصف امامنا ونعتقد
ان هناك دائما امكانيه التفاوض والتواصل
الى اتفاق قبل نهايه هذا الانذار النهائي
اذا فعلا نهايه هذه المهله والانذار يمكن
انذاك ان نتحدث فعلا عن تدخل منظمه
الاكواس اذا ما اصبح ذلك مر لا مفر منهم
هل هذا من باب التمني سيد محمد ام لديكم
معلومات او مؤشرات تقول بانه ربما يكون
هناك جديد على صعيد السياسي
تكلم ما نعرفه نحن هو ان مجموعه
ارسلت بعث للقاء للمسؤولين الانقلاب
وان
هذه البعثه او الوفد الذي ذهب لم يستطع ان
يقابل الرئيس
وعادوا
من مطار بعد ان اجر لقاء مع بعض اعضاء
الانقلابيين
بالتالي نعرف ايضا من جهه اخرى بان
الاتصالات مستمره
عن طريق قنوات اخرى وخاصه عن اتصالات
الهاتفيه وبالتالي للمناقشات ما زالت
جاريه والحوار لم يقطع تماما مع مجموعه
كلامك ان من قام باحتجاز الرئيس هو شخص
وربما تعني السيد عبد الرحمن
تتياني هل معنى ذلك بان هناك في داخل
الجيش من يرفض هذا الانقلاب ثم ماذا عن ما
شاهدناهم من المواطنين في العاصمه النيامي
خرجوا يدعمون هذا الانقلاب
[موسيقى]
احتجاز الرئيس ففعلا الامر يتعلق
بتصرف من قبل شخص فرد
والذي فجاه قرر بان يحتجز الشخص الذي
يفترض به ان يضمن سلامته وامنه ولم يحصل
اي استعدادات لانقلاب كما انقلاب اي ظروف
معينه كانت تقتضي تدخل من قبل الجيش
لانه كما تعلمون لم يكن هناك اي ازمه
سياسيه ولم تكنك اي ازمه اجتماعيه ولم تكن
هناك اي ازمه اقتصاديه وبالتالي لم يكن
هناك اي سبب يدعو الى تدخل من قبل الجيش
على الساحه السياسيه بل افضل من ذلك بل
حتى ذلك التاريخ النيجر كانت تعتبر واحده
ان الدول التي حققت اكبر قدر من التقدم
فعال الصعيد الديمقراطي وتعتبر واحد من
الدول التي يجري فيها الحوار السياسي
بطريقه جيده جدا وكذلك الحوار الاجتماعي
بشكل جيد وواحده من الدول التي حققت اكبر
التقدم ممكن على الصعيد الاقتصادي
بنسبه نمو
11.9% في عام 2022
ونسبه نمو
تقدم بسبعه بالمئه للسنه 2023 هو هناك
توقف زياده في النمو الاقتصادي به
234 وبالتالي فهذا امر كان غير هذا
الانقلاب ما كان متوقع ان اطلاقا
وفيما يتسمى دعوته انت بالدعم من الشعب
فانه كل مره اذا قلنا التظاهره في الشوارع
نجد الناس يقومون بالتعبئه المواطنين
واشخاص اخرين من العاطلين عن العمل
الاشخاص الذين
يودون لهم مستعدون لسبب محمد
ماذا ماذا عن فرنسا اخر التصريحات هذا
اليوم فرنسا مع اجراءات الاكواس بما فيها
التدخل العسكريا في حال عدم عوده الشرعيه
في النيجر ما الذي قيل لكم من قبل الجانب
الفرنسي وطبيعه الدور الفرنسي الان لاعاده
الشرعيه في النيجر
[موسيقى]
لا نستطيع ان نتحدث نيابه عن فرنسا
وكما قلت سيئ هذا
بين مجموعه
والانقلعبيين وليس بين حكومه نيجر
الانقلابيين وبالتالي مجموعه
يقول لك ما الذي اتفقوا عليه مع فرنسا في
حاله ان فرنسا
دعمتهم في هذه العمليه العسكريه سيد محمد
كذلك واعذرني على المقاطعه انت رئيس
الوزراء انت رئيس الوزراء هل انتم غير
مطلعين على اي شيء فقط الملف برمته عند
كما قلته
الاكواس حاليا تجري مناقشات مع فرنسا ومع
دول اخرى ولكن لا استطيع ان لكم ما الذي
اتفقوا عليه لا اعرف ما الذي اتفقوا عليه
في صباح هذا اليوم التقيته
الخارجيه الفرنسيه والتي اكدت لدعمها
للحكومه الشرعيه في النيجر هذا استطيع ان
اؤكده لكم بان فرنسا تدعم الحكومه الشرعيه
في النيجر وان فرنسا تؤيد عوده الرئيس
بازون الى الى منصبه الرئاسي وفرنسا تؤيد
عوده واستعاده كل المؤسسات التي يتظاهر
الانبيون قد حلوها
السيد حمود محمد رئيس وزراء النيجر كنت
معنا من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
ومعي من نيام الدكتور علي التاسع
الاكاديمي والدبلوماسي السابق اهلا بك
دكتور
وجودك معنا في هذه الساعات ساعات من
الترقب في العاصمه النيامي كيف هو الوضع
في نيامي الدكتور علي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
نرحب بكيفك الكريم معالي رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق
الوضع في نيابه هادئ جدا الوضع عادي
كل واحد يمشي الى اغراضه ما فيه اي تقلبات
ما في اي مشكله في نعمه هادئه مدينه هادئه
تماما
طيب استمعت ربما الى ما قاله رئيس الوزراء
قبل قليل يتحدث على انه ما زال هناك مجال
للتفاوض مصدر عسكري في ميامي قال للجزيره
بانه لا تراجع عن الاجراءات المتخذه
وبالتالي نحن امام اي مسار باعتقادك دكتور
علي
رقم احترامي لشخصيه رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
مع غموده ولكن
بكل صراحه ما تم انجازه من قبل هؤلاء
الضباب لا اعتقد انهم سيتراجعون ما فيه
مجال للتراجع في هذا المجال يعني لو كان
هناك
حل اخر لو وجد لكن
تقديم
مهله اسبوع والا سيتم شيء انا اعتقد انه
لا يمكن لاي ضابط عسكري ان يقبل مثل هذه
الشيء
طيب الايكواس يقولون بانهم لن يبلغوا
القاده في نيامي لا بموعد العمليه
العسكريه ولا في مكان الانزال كان هناك
انتشار لقوات الاكواس كيف تجد هذه
التصريحات
هي التشريحات
[موسيقى]
لاصحابها لكنني اقول لك الدول التي تقول
بانها ستقول جيوشا للدخول الى النيجر
تعاني من مشاكل في داخل
بلجحه في نيجيريا التي هي في السبت وانا
احترمها واحترم شعبها واعرف ان ما يذهب
اليه رئيسهم ليس راي الشعب
فنيجيريا لها مشاكل من بوكو هرم فيه مدن
لا يستطيع الجيش النيجيري ان يطا ان تطا
قدمه في هذه المدن ومدن يعني
يحتجزها سراق حتى وليس جيوشا في
ولايات عده مثل ولايه زنفره اماكن عده في
ولايه تبي في ولايه سوق الجيش الذي لم
يستطع ان يسدد ان يكنس امام بيته هل يمكن
ان ياتي يقول سيفرش بساط امام اخر لا
اعتقد ذلك لا تعتقدوا ذلك ماذا عن
التصريحات الفرنسيه ومدى جديه التدخل
العسكري وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه تقول
ندعم اجراءات الاكواس بما فيها التدخل
العسكري
فكل هذه التحركات ليست تحركات من قبل
الايكوس انما هي تحركات فرنسيه ففرنسا لها
مصالحها في النيجر ولا ليست مستعده
للتراجع عنها فهي بالنسبه لفرنسا قضيه
الحياه او الموت والا فرنسا كانت ترى مثل
هذه المشاكل تاتي لكن تعدد تعنتها
ومكابرتها جعلتها لا تتراجع ولا تستطيع
التحدث مع هذه الشعوب والا انا متاكد لو
ان فرنسا غيرت سياساتها تجاه هذه الدول
لما حدثت هذه الامور لكن استمرار فرنسا في
هذه الامور هي التي ادت الى ما نحن فيه
اليوم ففرنسا هي التي
تقف عائقا امام التقدم في هذه الدول لذلك
الشباب الاعلى ينضمون الى كل تحرك انقلابي
يكون عكس دوله فرنسا فالمشكله هي ان فرنسا
لا تفهم يعني كان يجب على الانسان لو قام
بعمل وراى انه لا يتراجع فالتراجع ليست
مشكله ففرنسا لا تتراجع ابدا ادركنا الوقت
من الدكتور علي التاسع الاكاديمي
والدبلوماسي السابق شكرا جزيلا لك
للتدخل عسكريا في النيجر متعدده لكن دونها
عقبات وتبعات نتعرف عليها في هذا العرض
كيف ومتى سيتم نشر قوات دول المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لغرب افريقيا في النيجر ذاك ما
يعلمه قاده اركان جيوش المجموعه الذين
وضعوا خطه لتدخل عسكري محتمل لا مجال
لتحديد موعد الضربه لكن بين الثنايا
تفاصيل القرار حرب النفسيه وابعاد
عملياتيه متعلقه بالتخطيط للتدخل العسكري
لن تخبر مدبريه الانقلاب متى واين سنضرب
هذا قرار عملي سيتخذه رؤساء الدول
بين الخيارات غزو بري خصوصا من دول داعمه
للتدخل كان نيجيريا وبنين المجاورتين لكنه
سيكون عمليه كبيره قد تستغرق اسابيع
وتنطوي على مخاطر كبيره تفتح الباب لصراع
طويل الامد وزعزعه استقرار المنطقه خيار
اخر وهو خوض عمليه بقوه ارضيه من القوه
الخاصه اقل حجما تكون اسرع في التجميع
ويرجح ان تركز على الاستيلاء على المواقع
الامنيه والاداريه الرئيسيه وانقاذ بازوم
من الاقامه الجبريه واعاده حكومته
يمكن لاكواس ان تسعى للحصول على دعم
الاستخبارات من القوه الامريكيه والفرنسيه
داخل النيجر والجدول الزمني لتنفيذ ذلك
سيكون اقصر لكنما خطره تحيط بالخطه بسبب
دعم جزء من الشارع للانقلاب ورفض التدخل
الاجنبي وفق محللين السيناريو الثالث قد
يكون دعما محدودا لانقلاب المضاد مع عدم
وضوح مقدار الدعم الذي ستقدمه المجموعات
المختلفه للقاده الجدد فدل حديث عن
انقسامات بين القوات المسلحه في النيجر
وقد تبدو هذه الخيارات امام معطيات مرتبطه
بالدعم الاقليمي او الدولي فحتى الان
اعلنت السنغال وبنين ونيجيريا استعدادها
للمشاركه في القوه العسكريه الموجهه الى
النيجر ولا يستبعد ان تنخرط تشاد ايضا في
ذلك لكن تعقيدات متضافره هي الاخرى تحول
دون التقدم نحو خيار من هذا القبيل فاميلي
وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا حذرت من ان اي تدخل
عسكري في النيجر سيكون بمثابه اعلان حرب
عليها
وسرعت الجزائر من خارج دول اكواس والتي
تملك حدودا بالف كيلومتر مع النيجر
للتعبير عن موقف صارم ضد تدخل العسكري
خشيه تصاعد موجه العنف في المنطقه وان دعت
لعوده النظام الدستوري في النيجر قد تراهن
اكواس على فرنسا التي تمتاز بامتلاكها قوه
عسكريه على اراضي النيجر ويمكن ان تكون
عنصر ارتكاز لدعم اي تدخل عسكري لكن هذا
التدخل لا يبدو محل اتفاق اوروبي حيث دعا
وزير الخارجيه الايطالي الى استبعاده وضمن
المعادله ياتي موقف روسيا الرافضه لاي
تدخل عسكري وهي المتهمه السابقا بدعم غير
مباشر لما حدث في مالي وبوركينا فاسو
المجاورتين
[موسيقى]
قالت الوكاله الفيدراليه الروسيه للنقل
البحري ان النقل الروسيه اس اي جي تعرضت
لهجوم بزورق مسير قرب شبه جزيره القرم
تسبب في حدوث ثقب في غرفه المحركات على
جانب الناقل الايمن من جانبه قال مصدر
استقباري اوكراني ان زورقا مسيرا ضرب
ناقله نفط تحمل وقودا للقوات الروسيه وفي
اعلن حاكم المدينه رصدا زورق مسير بالقرب
من مدينه
واشار الى اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لتدمير
الزورق
حرب البحر الاسود تتوسع وتاخذ ابعد حرب
استنزاف جديده مره اخرى تلجا القوات
الاوكرانيه الى مسيرات بحريه لضرب اهداف
روسيه بالقرب من جسر كيرش الذي يربط روسيا
بشبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها عام 2014
استهدفت مسيره اوكرانيه ناقله نفط روسيه
مصادر في امن الدوله وسلاح الجو الاوكراني
قالت ان الناقله كانت تحمل وقودا للقوات
الروسيه واوضحت ان المسيره التي استهدفت
الناقله الروسيه كانت تحمل 450 من
المتفجرات اعترفت الوكاله الفيدراليه
الروسيه للنقل البحري بان الناقله الروسيه
تعرضت للهجوم الذي تسبب في ثقب بغرفه
المحركات على جانب الناقله الايمن
ما يزيد من خطوره الهجوم انه وقع بالقرب
من جسر كرش وتسبب في توقف الحركه على
الجسر ثلاث ساعات توعدت روسيا بالرد على
الهجوم الذي وصفته بالارهابي وقال ديمتري
الرئيس السابق ونائب مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي ان بلاده ستنفذ مزيدا من الهجمات
على الموانئ الاوكرانيه والتي ستنهي اي
امر في احياء اتفاق الحبوب حسب تعبيره
وتوعد اوكرانيا بكارثه بيئيه لم يحدد
معالمها في هذه الحرب البحريه تبقى شبه
جزيره القرم الهدف الابرز للقوات
الاوكرانيه حاكم التي يوجد بها مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي قال انه تم رصد مسيره
بحريه واتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لتدميرها
قبل هذه الهجمات بساعات قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت سفينه حربيه
روسيه في ميناء
جنوبي روسيا وتحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن رصد مسيرتين اوكرانيتين متجهتين الى
الميناء اعتبرت الاوكرانيه الهجوم على
الميناء في الجنوب الروسي رساله الى موسكو
مفادها ان الموانئ الروسيه ليست في مامن
بل ان وكاله الملاحه الاوكرانيه وجه
التحذيرا لسته موانئ قاعده انها تعتبرها
منطقه مخاطر حربيه
تاتي هذه التحركات الاوكرانيه بعد الضربات
التي طالت موانئ اوكرانيه اثر انسحاب
روسيا من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب تعدت الهجمات
الروسيه موانئ البحر الاسود ووصلت الى
الموانئ النهريه الاوكرانيه على نهر
الدانوب ويبدو ان كيايف تحاول استخدام
المسيرات وسيله للردع ولتحقيق نوع من
التوازن العسكري في البحر الاسود
معنا ملكيه
الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ومن موسكو اندريه المحلل
السياسي والعسكري اهلا بكم ابدا بضيف من
موسكو السيد اندري ما كان في السابق
عمليات اوكرانيه تسميها كيا بانها عمليات
رمزيه ولكن كانت متباعده زمنيا ما يحدث
هذه الايام عمليات نوعيه يقوم بها الجانب
الاوكراني ولكنها تكون شبه يوميه ما تفسير
ذلك
اعتقد ان هذا شيء واضح فهو نوع من الهجمات
الارهابيه ضد روسيا
وقد قتل عفوا وقد استهدفت ناقله مدنيه
وبالتالي وجهه نظر عسكريه هذه الهجمات
ليست مضره وليست مهمه واعتقد ان روسيا
ستحاول
تدمير هذه القوارب المسيره وفي قواعدها
وايضا المنشات التي
تصنع حمله لهذه
المسيرات البحريه سيد يوريساك كما سمعتها
يقول استهداف
ناقله نفط او هدف مدني وليس عسكري كما
يقول الجانب الاوكراني ماذا عن هذه
العمليات النوعيه بل وحتى التحذير بان ست
موانئ روسيه في البحر الاسود هي محل
استهداف
اولا هذا الامر لم هذا لم تكن ناقله مدنيه
بل هي ناقله كانت تنقل النفط المعرض
للعقوبات الى سوريا وامر لا ينبغي ان يحصل
موجب القانون الدولي اصلا بالنسبه لنا اي
شيء روسي ويحمل معدات او او النفط يمكن ان
يباع ثم تستخدم اموال لنفط هذا لقتل الشعب
الاوكراني
ومثلا على سبيل المثال اليوم لما نحسب
الامور لكن بعد الظهر اليوم تعرضت
اوكرانيا الى هجمات صاروخيه كانت مكثفه
فعندما
يقول
الروس ان هذا امر ارهابي فهذا امر سخيف
لان هناك فقط طرف واحد ارهابي هنا وهو
روسيا واننا قلنا وبشكل واضح بان البحر
الاسود ليس مكانا امنا للاسطول الروسي
وسنواصل استهداف الاسطول الروسي في منطقه
البحر الاسود في الاراضي الاقليميه
لاوكرانيا وهذه نقطه مهمه نحن لا نخترق اي
قانون دولي
وبالتالي فان روسيا كانت تعتقد ان
بامكانهم يقوموا
باطلاق ضرب المدن الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ
دون عقوبه انهم مخطئون اذا سيدوري يبدو
كما سمعت لضيفي من هي المواجهه تضرب اضرب
السن بالسن والعين بالعين الان ما البدائل
المطروحه امام موسكو في التعامل مع هذه
النهج الجديد من قبل الجانب الاوكراني
وهذه العمليه المتكرره
كما قلت ان هذا النوع من الهجمات لا من
ناحيه العسكريه غير مهمه وان الضيف من كيف
قال ان اوكرانيا
لا تهاجم فقط
[موسيقى]
منطقه
التي هي خارج روسيا وبالتالي اعتقد ان
روسيا ستواصل منهجها الاستراتيجي في
اوكرانيا للتدمير كل منشاتها العسكريه وكل
منشاتها الاقتصاديه التي تغذي جهود
الحربيه لاقرين وان مثل هذه النوع من
الهجمات نرى كما نرى الان اصبحت طريقه
جديده
للهجوم روسيا على
السيد يولي تقول هذه العمليات غير مهمه
ولكنها ستجعل الملاحه في البحر الاسود
اكثر صعوبه ستعطل هذه الموانئ
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه في البحر الاسود
خاصه فيما يتعلق
بشبه جزيره القرم وحتى الملاحه البحريه
الروسيه وبالتالي لماذا تراها غير مهمه او
ما تفسير ذلك
هذا ليس صحيح لان المباني الموانئ الروسيه
مفتوحه
وسفن الشحن متواصل الوصول اليها التحرك
منها وهذا مجرد هجمات بسيطه من واحد او
اثنين اوروبا ثلاثه زوارق لا تستطيع ان
تؤثر على خطوط امدادات من روسيا الى
العالم طيب في هذه الحاله
ايضا سمعتها ضيفي من موسكو هل باستطاعه
ثياب ان تواصل هذا النهج العسكري في ظل ما
يتسبب فيه هذه العمليات من خسائر كبيره في
الجانب الاوكراني سيد اندريه
سيد يوري عفوا
كما قلت سنواصل ضربه
روسيا اينما كنت كانت هناك ضروره لان
روسيا هي التي تواجهنا تضربنا هذه حرب نحن
ندخلها بالدفاع عن اراضينا وموجب ميثاق
الامم المتحده يحق لنا الدفاع عن انفسنا
وهذا هو بالضبط ما نقوم به وان وان قاده
العسكريون والسيا
قالوا هذا
هذه ليست مره الاولى تعرض بها السفن
الروسيه للقصف اننا سنر جهود كبيره موارد
كثيره لتطوير قدراتنا
المركزيه بالمسيرات وخاصه مسيرات البحريه
شكرا لك اثبتنا هناك واعتذر
وانت مستشار وزير الدفاع المتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الاوكراني وكذلك لضيفي من
موسكو اندري فرولوف المحلل السياسي
والعسكري
هذا وقالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
قصفا روسيا استهدف العاصمه كييف بصواريخ
كروس بدوره اكد الرئيس
استهداف مصنع محركات الطائرات في زفروشيا
وبشان اعمال الاجتماع التشاوري لمستشاري
الامن الوطني عدد من الدول بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه قال زيلينسكي ان جميع
المشاركين متحدون على اولويه تطبيق
القانون الدولي
يعمل فريقنا في جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في اجتماع مستشاري قاده الدول
على صيغه السلام هناك ممثلون عن 42 دوله
من قاره عده مقاربه سياسيه مختلفه لشؤون
العالميه لكن الجميع متحدون في اولويه
القانون الدولي ولهذا السبب اقترحت
اوكرانيا صيغه السلام يجب اعاده النظام
الدولي القائم على القواعد الذي انتهكه
العدوان الروسي من المهم جدا ان تجري هناك
على هامش اجتماع جده مفاوضات ثنائيه مع
الشركاء
هذا وتتواصل في جده اعمال الاجتماع
التشاوري بشان الازمه الاوكرانيه ويشارك
فيه ممثلون عن نحو 40 دوله واشارت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه الى ان الرياض تتطلع الى
ان يسمى الاجتماع في تعزيز الحوار
والتعاون على المستوى الدولي بشان حل
الازمه الاوكرانيه وبما يجنب العالم مزيدا
من التداعيات الانسانيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه وياتي ذلك عندما نقلت وكاله
سبوتنيك عن مصدر بوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ان السعوديه ابلغت روسيا انها ستطلعها على
نتائج الاجتماع وقالت الصين انها ستوفد
مسؤولا بارزا الى السعوديه لحضور اجتماع
جده الراوي لايجاد تسويه سلميه للحرب في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى تل ابيب حيث قالت وسائل اعلام
الاسرائيليه ان رجلا الامن الاسرائيلي
الذي اصيب في عمليه اطلاق نار بمنطقه
نحليه نيابيين توفي متاثرا بجراحه وقالت
الشرطه انها قتلت المشتبهه في تنفيذه
عمليه اطلاق النار وقاد المفتش العام
للشرطه الاسرائيليه ان منفذ الهجوم من
قريه رمانه قضاء جنين وان بحوزته وصيه كتب
فيها انه جاء ليستشهد هذا وقالت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان المجلس الامني الوزاري
الاسرائيليه المصغر سيجتمع يوم غد الاحد
هذا وقالت حركه حماس ان عمليه اطلاق النار
في تل ابيب هي عمل بطولي ردا على تصعيد
ميليشيات المستوطنين جرائمها بحق
الفلسطينيين واضافت الحركه ان استمرار
عمليات المقاومه يؤكد مجددا قدره الشعب
الفلسطيني على اصابه العدو في مقتل بينما
قال الناطق باسم حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
طارق سلمي ان الحركه تبارك عمليه اطلاق
النار الفدائيه في تل ابيب واضاف ان
المخططات التي تستهدف المسجد الاقصى
ستقابل بمزيد من عمليات المقاومه وقال
سلمى ان العمليه جاءت ردا طبيعيا على
جرائم القتل اليوميه التي ينفذها الاحتلال
في الضفه الغربيه
بالاثناء قالت المصادر الفلسطينيه ان
الاجهزه الامنيه التابعه للسلطه قمعت
مسيره خرجت في جنين وذلك تاييدا للعمليه
التي قام بها فلسطيني في تل ابيب واضافت
المصادر ان عناصر الامن اطلقوا قنابل
الغاز باتجاه المتظاهرين كما سمعت اصوات
اطلاق نار خلال تفريق المسيره
واشارت المصادر الى اصابه صحفي الصحفي علي
سمودي في راسه بشظايا اعيره ناريه كما
اصيب الصحفي محمد عابد بقنبله غاز في قدمه
[موسيقى]
مواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده جبل المكبر
بالقدس المحتله واقتحمت قوه الاحتلال
البلده وسط اطلاق القنابل الصوت والغاز
المسيلي للدموع تجاه الفلسطينيين الذين
ردوا بالقاء الحجاره والمرفاقعات الناريه
هذا ولم تسجل اي اصابات او اعتقالات في
صفوف الشبان الفلسطينيين
قال منسق الامم المتحده لعمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط
انه يدين بشده اعمال المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين الذين او التي عفوا وقعت
بالضفه الغربيه ومنها اطلاق النار على شاب
فلسطيني يبلغ من العمر 19 عاما خرجت او
خلال مواجهات بين فلسطينيين ومستوطني بؤره
استيطانيه غير قانونيه وطلب بالتحقيق في
الحادث وتحميل الجونات المسؤوليه وتفادي
مزيد من العنف
قصف جيش السوداني بالمدفعيه الثقيله ما
وقع تابعه لقوه الدعم السريع في مدن
العاصمه الثلاث ويقول الجيش انه يتقدم في
عدد من مواقع ارتكاز الدعم السريع بينما
تنفي قوه الدعم السريع ذلك وتقول انها ما
تزال تحاصل القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
في مبنى المخابرات العامه بالخرطوم في هذه
الاثناء حذرت نائبه رئيس بعثه الامم
المتحده الخاصه لدعم الانتقال بالسودان من
ان الاوضاع الانسانيه بلغت حدا مروعا
[موسيقى]
لليوم الحادي عشر بعد المئه تتواصل
المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع قصف الجيش بالمدفعيه الثقيله مواقع
الدعم في منطقه جبرا وسوف جنوبي الخرطوم
ومنطقه شرق النيل ووسط وجنوبي وغربي ام
درمان ومحيط سلاح المدرعات في المدينه
ويركز الجيش في تصريحاته على استمرار
عملياته اليوميه التي تستهدف اخراج قوات
الدعم السريع من مواقع ارتكاذها في مدن
العاصمه الثلاث ويقول ان هذه القوات تتكبد
خسائر بشريه وماديه فادحه ونشر الجيش صورا
قال انها لعمليات التمشيط نفذتها قواته
الخاصه في منطقه ام درمان العسكريه وسط
انباء تتحدث ايضا عن اشتباكات عنيفه
وتمشيط سوق ام درمان ومنطقه ابو روف
واحياء وسط المدينه
في الوقت نفسه تنفي قوات الدعم السريع
تقدم الجيش في عدد من مواقعه
ومع استمرار المواجهات تتكشف يوميا المزيد
من التداعيات التي توصف محليا واقليميا
ودوليا بالمروعه وتضع البلاد على شفير
مجاعه وحذرت نائبه رئيس بعثه الامم
المتحده الخاصه لدعم الانتقال بالسودان
كالمنتاين كويتاسلامي من تفاقم الامور
وقالت خلال زيارتها لمراكز متضررين في
ولايتي كسلا والقضارف شرقي السودان قالت
ان الاحتياجات الانسانيه في ازدياد وهناك
حاجه لمزيد من الدعم بشكل عاجل
ومع غياب اي اشارات لنهايه المواجهات منذ
تعثر عدد من المبادرات المطروحه يتم الان
الحديث عن لقاء مرتقب لوزراء خارجيه
الدولي جوار السودان في تشاد وذكر انه
سيبحث جوانب الازمه بجميع ابعادها الامنيه
والسياسيه والانسانيه
وتاثيراتها وسبل وقف اطلاق النار
الى باكستان حيث قال مراسل الجزيره الى
السلطات الامن تحتجز رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان في سجن باقليم البنجاب وكانت
محكمه ابتدائيه في اسلام اباد قد قضت بسجن
عمران خان ثلاثه سنوات بتهمه سوء التصرف
في هدايا تلقاها خلال تقلده منصب رئاسه
الوزراء وقال وزير الاعلام الباكستاني
جرى بعد اجراءات قانونيه سليمه في
المحاكمه ولا علاقه له بالانتخابات من
جهته دعاخان مؤيديه الى عدم السكوت على
اعتقاله وسجده
ليس موكب تشريفات كما اعتاد عليه رئيس
الحكومه السابق عمران خان بل كان اقتيدا
من قوات الامن الى السجن
فقد حكمت عليه المحكمه الابتدائيه في
العاصمه اسلام اباد بالسجن ثلاثه سنوات
ومنعه من النشاط السياسي لخمس سنوات
التهمه هي الفساد في طريقه تصرفه في هدايا
دوله خلال توليه منصب رئيس الحكومه
لكن عمران خان اعتبر كل هذا مكيده ضد
الشعب ولحرمانه من المشاركه في الانتخابات
التشريعيه المرتقبه في شهر اكتوبر المقبل
بالباكستانية ايها الشعب حين يصلكم هذا
التسجيل ساكون قد اعتقلت ونقلت الى السجن
لدي مناشده واحده لكم ايها الشعب لا تبقوا
جالسين وساكتين في بيوتكم عليكم الاحتجاج
سلميا ما لم تحصلوا على حقكم وهو حق مبدئي
ان تنتخبوا من يحكمكم لا ان تسمحوا لمن
يسيطر على الدوله حاليا ان يحكمكم
الحكومه نفت اي علاقه لها بادانه عمران
خان واتهمته بالسعي لتضليل الشعب
التحقيق في فساد خان استمر لمده سنه وعلى
مدار 40 جلسه وبعد اتخاذ كل الاجراءات
القانونيه تمت اداناته وفضح سرقاته وهناك
المزيد من السرقات التي سيكشف عنها قريبا
حزبه انصاف الذي يتزعمه عمران خان خسر
معظم قاده الصفين الاول والثاني وانشق عنه
معظم نوابه في البرلمانات بعد اتهامات
وادانه اعلاميه للحزب بالتورط في مهاجمه
مؤسسات الدوله ومقر عسكريه في مايو الماضي
احتجاجا على مجرد ايقاف خان يومها للتحقيق
تقلب ساحه السياسيه في باكستان عاده ما
يكون حادا ومفاجئا فامران خان الذي طالما
حشد اتباعه في هذه الساحه لم يخرج انصاره
حتى الان
عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
فعل ثم رد فعلتها واتهام يقابله اخر على
هذا النحو يمضي التصعيد بين واشنطن وطهران
في مضيق هرمز اخر هذه التطورات هو قرار
ايران تزويد بحريتها التابعه للحرس الثوري
بطائرات مسيره وصواريخ وجاء في الاعلان ان
بعض الصواريخ الجديده يبلغ مداها الفكم
كما تتمتع بدقه افضل كما قال الجانب
الايراني وجاءت هذه الخطوه بعد ان عرضت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعيين بحاره
ومشاه بحريه لحراسه السفن التجاريه التي
تمر عبر مضيق هرمز ويمر نحو خمس النفط
الخام في العالم عبر مضيق هرمز الذي تحده
من الشمال ايران ومن الجنوب سلطنه عمان
يبلغ عرض هذا المضيق 50 كلم وعمق المياه
فيه يصل الى 60 مترا عرض هذا الممر المائي
الدخول والخروج فيه اكثر من عشره
كيلومترات ويستوعب من عشرين الى ثلاثين
ناقله نفط يوميا استنادا لاحد الباحثين
تريد واشنطن مراقبه سير الملاحه في مضيق
هذا المضيق مضيق هرمز وفي مياه الخليج وفي
شمال المحيط الهندي وتريد ايضا الاداره
اداره اي احتكاك قد يحدث في هذه المنطقه
تعمل الولايات المتحده منذ سنوات على
تعزيز قواتها العامله في مضيق هرمز وسبق
ان اعلنت قبل فتره عزمها على نشر مدمره
وطائرات حربيه من طراز اف 35 واف سته عشر
اضافه الى مجموعه استعداد برمائيه ووحده
استطلاء ووحده استطلاعيه بحريه تتالف من
نحو 3000 عنصر الجيش الامريكي يقول ان
ايران احتجزت او حاولت السيطره على قرابه
عشرين سفينه في المنطقه خلال العامين
الماضيين واعلنت واشنطن ايضا ان قواتها
منعت محاولتين ايرانيتين لاحتجاز ناقلات
تجاريه في المياه الدوليه قباله عمان وذلك
في الخامس من يوليو بينما صادر الطهران
سفينه تجاريه في اليوم الذي يليه في ابريل
او اوائل مايو صادرت ايران ناقلتين في
غضون اسبوع في المياه الاقليميه كما اتهمت
بشن هجوم بطائره مسيره على ناقله مملوكه
لشركه اسرائيليه في نوفمبر 2022
تكررت هذه الحوادث منذ عام 2018 بعد
الانسحاب الاحادي للولايات المتحده في عهد
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب من الاتفاق
النووي الايراني واعاده فرض عقوبات شديده
على الجمهوريه الاسلاميه عن هذا الملف
معنا
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك دكتور
خليل
جمله معطيات
صعبت قراءه المشهد هل هذه الاجراءات
الامريكيه متعلقه فعلا بموضوع الناقلات ام
ان هناك ابعاد اخرى عندما تقوم ايران
باجراء مناورات بصواريخ تصل الى الف وكذلك
الى 600 كيلومتر يصبح المشهد يحتاج الى
تفسير
انا اعتقد هناك عدد المتغيرات في هذا
الموضوع الاستاذ عبد القادر جزء منه متعلق
بان هناك مناورات ايرانيه مستمره في في
منطقه الخليج العربي خاصه بالقرب هرمز
الامر متعلق اولا بما تراه امريكا سعي
ايراني لفرض الهيمنه على هذا الممر
الاقليمي المائي الذي كما جاء في التقرير
يمر منه على الاقل خمس تجاره النفط
العالميه ومشتقاتها المختلفه وبالتالي
هناك حاجه امريكيه لضمان عدم حدود اهتزاز
في سوق النفط العالميه قد يؤثر سلبا على
الاوضاع بشكل عام الامر الاخر متعلق بانه
اتهامات امريكيه مستمره بوجود نوايا
وافعال ايرانيه متعلقه باحتجاز ناقلات نفط
ونقلات تجاريه حسب ما جاء قبل قليل على
اقل حسب الاحصاءات الامريكيه على اقل
عشرين محاوله
لاحتجاز ناقلات بحريه وتجاريه قامت به
ايران وبالتالي هذا يعتبر نوع من القرصنه
تقوم بايران فيما يتعلق الملف الامر
الثالث متعلق رايي الشخصي ايضا ارسال
تقنينات لدول الخليج العربي فيما يتعلق
بحمايه الامن باقليم الخليجي خاصه في ظل
وجود شعور عربي شعور خليجي عام نوع من
الانسحاب خاصه في ظل الانشغال امريكا
بالصراع مع الصين في بعض الصين
على اوكرانيا امريكا في الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا بشكل ابخره وبالتالي محاوله
امريكا القيام او الخطط بارسال ووضع جنود
من المشاهد البحريه الامريكيه على ناقلات
تجاريه قد يعطي نوع من الضمان او نوع من
الامن لا دول الخليج العربي بان ليس هناك
دكتور خليل هناك تساؤل ما الذي اختلف
الوجود العسكري الامريكي دائما موجود في
المنطقه قامت ايران او اتهمت باحتجاز بعض
الناقلات ولم تستعمل واشنطن القوه
لمنع ذلك ما الذي اختلف الان وهل هناك
سؤال هل ستقوم
واشنطن باستعمال القوه هذه المره في حال
حدوث هذا الامر
بالنسبه بقى من السؤال لابد ان نفرق بين
امرين بين وجود عسكري امريكي فعلا كبير
وكثيف في المنطقه الخليج العربي على اقل
منذ اربعه خمسه عقود نتكلم على الاقل عن
70 الف جندي امريكي متوزعين وموزعين على
مجموعه من القاعده العسكريه سواء كان في
الامارات او في قطر او في البحرين مقر
الاسطوره الخامس الامريكي او حتى في
العراق والكويت وايضا في برضو شمال سوريا
والامر الثاني متعلق هذا المره هو الجديد
عبد القادر وهو وضع جنود مشاه بحريه
امريكيه على سطح نقلات تجاريه هذا امر
جديد وغير مسكوك من قبله كما قلت هذا وهذا
ياتي لجزء الاخر من السؤال متعلق منه في
رايي الشخصي بنوع من وجود ضغط امريكي على
ايران فيما يتعلق بملف النووي ايراني
ودائما نتابع عندما يكون هناك نوع من
الضغط واستخدام الاوراق مختلفه هلاقي بعد
هناك نوع من الانسداد في في مقابلات الملف
النووي الايراني وبالتالي تستخدم كارت
مقابل كارت او تستخدم ورق التفاوض مقابل
ورقه اخرى وبالتالي قد يكون امر مرتبط
بوجود تعثر ما في مفارق النووي الايراني
وهذه محاوله من اجل الضغط على ايران رضعها
بشكل اخر والقول بانه
يعني كامريكا موجودين في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي هناك حاجه التواصل الاتفاق فيما
يتعلق بالاتفاق النووي الايراني وبالتالي
دكتور خليل في المقابل ايضا ايران تقوم
وتجري مناورات بشكل فجائي مناورات غير
معلنه هي اوسع جغرافيه تقول لحمايه
الجزر ولكن ايضا تستعمل اسلحه نوعيه كما
ذكرت بعضها يصل الى مسافات طويله جدا ان
كان الامر ياتي ردا على هذه الاجراءات
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بمضيق هرمز ما
الداعي لتقديم هذه الاسلحه في هذه
المناورات الايرانيه ما الرساله
اعتقد الرساله واضحه تماما وهو ان منطقه
الخليج العربي وخاصه منطقه هرمز يعتبر
فناء خلفي لايران وبالتالي لن يسمع
الاطلاق بوجود اي قوه اخرى قد تناهض او قد
تؤثر على مصالح الايرانيه في تلك المنطقه
من العالم هذا التحول او هذا التطور او
جزء منه ردا على ما قالته امريكا بالامس
بامكانيه ارسال او وضع جنود
امريكانا على نقلات نقلات تجاريه هذا
يعتبر نوع من التحدي بشكل او باخر لامريكا
نوع من فرد السيطره فرد الهيمنه باعتبار
ان منطقه مضيق هرمز هي منطقه منطقه نفوز
ايراني وبالتالي حتى وان اعلنت امريكا
وجود حمايه ماليه هذه نقلات نحن قادرين
على الوصول ابعد درجه في هذه المساله وانا
اعتقد الامر هنا متعلق بالصراع ايرادات
بين الطرفين كما قلت قبل قليل هناك عده
ملفات معقده بين طرفين ايران والامريكي
جزء منه متعلق بكيفيه استخدام او او يعني
لعبه النفوس في هذه المنطقه
المتوتره من العالم والمهمه ايضا كما قلت
قبل قليل العالمي وبالتالي انا جزء من
رسائل الايرانيه لامريكا انه مهما فحاولت
ان تقومي بوضع او تقويه نفوزك نحن ايضا
موجودون وبالامس القريب يعني قبل حوالي
يومين كانت هناك مناورات عسكريه ايرانيه
كيلو متر في جزيره جزيره ابو موسى المحتله
من الامارات وهذا ايضا يعتبر رساله ايضا
قويه جدا من ايران لواحده من اهم حلفاء
دوله العربيه المتحده وبالتالي نحن ازاء
لعبه مستمره من الشكر ما اخشاه يعني مرحله
هو حدوث ان تخرج عن السيطره بمعنى اخر ان
تقوم ايران مثلا باستهداف بعض جنود
الامريكيين
يتعلق بامكانيه القنبله قدر الله الدكتور
خالد العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لك
كتاب هذا الحصار الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]